nous allons reprendre nos
travaux et donc nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir le président le serf
président de la CNSA et la directrice
Madame Virginie Magnan donc pour une
audition concernant notamment la
proposition de loi portant mesures pour
bâtir la société du bienvillir je vous
rappelle pour tous que ce texte sera
examiné par notre commission dès la
semaine de rentrée parlementaire
c'estdire le mercredi 17 janvier 2024
puis en séance à partir du mardi 30
janvier voilà donc c'était la dernière
audition de 2023 vous clôturez nos
travaux pour 2023 voilà donc
concrètement monsieur le Président
Madame la Directrice nous aimerons avoir
votre point de vue et donc la position
générale de la CNSA sur le texte que
nous examinons et en même temps ce qui
sera intéressant c'est d'avoir un peu
cette cette relation ce parallèle avec
notamment la C qui vous qui vous qui
vous motive pour voir comment il y a à
la fois des des points communs et des
des points complémentaire donc on
aimerait avoir votre position ensuite
nous donnerons la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs Jean sol et jusine guidez
puis ensuite mais les ensemble des
sénateurs qui souhaiteront s'exprimer
vous connaissez l'exercice monsieur le
Président je vous donne la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur président très honoré
de de clôturer effectivement les
auditions pour cette année 2023 euh très
heureux de de de me retrouver
effectivement parmi vous cette maison
est une maison qui est fort chère à mon
cœur
euh euh parler de cette PPL c'est c'est
d'abord effectivement au nom de de de
tout le conseil et et puis on répondra
ensuite effectivement aux question
Virginie Manan enchaînera d'ailleurs sur
le problème de la COG puisque c'est une
question qui lui tient très à cœur même
si le président de de de de du Conseil
d' CNSA souhaiterait qu'il y ait un
avenant à la COG parce que la COG elle a
été signé par moi d'ailleurs pour la
CNSA je venais juste d'arriver donc le
travail avait été accompli beaucoup plus
par ma prédécesseur Marianne Monchamp
mais depuis cette signature qui n'est
pourtant pas très ancienne il y a eu les
élections présidentielles il y a eu les
élections législatives il y a eu de
nouveaux engagements qui ont été pris
par le gouvernement et donc il y a des
avenants qui seront nécessaires pour que
les promesses gouvernementales puissent
effectivement se concrétiser vous dire
d'abord que cette PPL le conseil de de
la CNSA on a bien sûr parlé à de très
nombreuses reprises et que dans un
premier s il a exprimé un regret un
regret qui je crois est assez unanime
pour ne pas dire totalement unanime au
sein de ce conseil dans toutes ses
composantes sauf les composantes état
donc je ne dirai pas ce qu'ell pens puis
que généralement elles ne prennent pas
par au vote de toute façon sur les
problèmes qu' a engage les pouvoirs
publics mais le conseil de la CNSA dans
toutes ces autres composantes a regretté
qu'il n'y ait pas effectivement de
grandes loi sur l'autonomie et quand je
on parle de grande loi sur l'autonomie
c'est une loi qui aurait embrassé à la
fois fois le problème des personnes
âgées et des personnes en situation de
handicap avec la volonté d'avoir
réellement un texte qui soit un
véritable phare pour les les les les les
les
dispositions législatives ultérieures
c'està-dire il sagissit pas de tout
prévoir en une seule grande loi mais que
au moins le le le le phare soit donné
qui sache vers quel destination on
pouvait se se diriger les problèmes
fondamentaux étant bien sûr les
problèmes de la amélioration des
conditions de vie pour ces personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité et avec le
Corire qui est totalement indissociable
de l'attractivité des métiers de
l'accompagnement et du soin de la même
façon le le le nous souhaitions voir
affirmer alors c'est en train de se
faire mais d'une manière qui est une
manière peut-être plus plus plus diluée
affirmer la nécessité de la fin d'un
choix réducteur entre le domicile
traditionnel et puis l'Pad euh euh
nécessité encore rappelé aujourd'hui par
les nouvelles dérives que l'on constate
dans un certain nombre effectivement
d'épades commerciaux hein euh on a eu
l'affaire Européa qui a fait beaucoup de
de de de mal je crois il y a désormais
beaucoup de de de de de rumeurs et même
plus que des rumeurs qui courent sur
d'autres structures comme emra et j'ai
beaucoup de présidents de département
qui viennent me dire moi j'ai des épades
qui ne sont plus désormais remplis qu'à
60 65 % qu'est-ce qu'on fait je l' ferme
je les ferme pas et où un des conseils
que l'on peut parfois leur donner c'est
de les aider à transformer effectivement
les pades en résidence autonomie qui ne
présenterait pas les inconvénients
vis-à-vis de de de de de la citoyenneté
des uns et des autres et vis-à-vis de la
dignité qui est qui est proposée à des
personnes qui sont encore très largement
valides alors que dans un certain nombre
de situation où on a des épades avec
uniquement des personnes en extrême fin
de vie ou des personnes qui sont en
situation de de très grande dépendance
on a du mal à faire émerger ce qu'on
appelle effectivement l'appréhension
domiciliaire de la même façon je ne veux
pas parler aujourd'hui de la réflexion
sur la fin de vie mais nous pensons que
dans la grande loi elle aurait eu
également sa place non pas pour décider
de tout ce qui devait être le le la
législation de demain mais pour encore
une fois fixer les
orientations sur à la place si vous
voulez de cette grande loi on a vu se
multiplier des initiatives fort
intéressantes d'ailleurs les unes et les
a autres mais qui sont des initiatives
compartimentées si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi à la fois le le le Conseil
national de la refondation dans dans
dans dans dans son prisme bien vieillir
la Conférence nationale du handicap la
stratégie bien vieillir avec la
présentation d'une feuille de route
interministérielle et donc la
mobilisation d'un d'un grand nombre de
membres du gouvernement qui s'est faite
au mois dernier et enfin cette
proposition de de loi remise à l'ordre
du jour du du Parlement après quelques
alléas et qui désormais arrive
effectivement devant le Sénat euh le le
le cette proposition nous paraît
intéressante avec les limites qui sont
les limites inhérentes au PPL notamment
la limite couprès de l'article 40 et et
et de de de la possibilité effectivement
de de de de dégager des ressources
nouvelles ou ou et ou de l'impossibilité
pour pour la PPL euh qui pose quand même
un certain nombre de de de de de
questions et et je souhaitais simplement
avant de de laisser la parole si
monsieur le Président le veut bien à à
Madame la Directrice de la CNSA insister
sur les points qui paraissent pour le le
la CNSA des des points clés sur le texte
de de la proposition de loi et des
points sur lesquels nous sommes en
harmonie et nous souhaiterions
effectivement que les choses puissent
peut-être évoluer le plus rapidement
possible on a par exemple reçu
avec satisfaction la promesse du une loi
pluriannuelle sur le le le le
financement effectivement de l'autonomie
qui devrait être voté avant la fin de
l'année prochaine et qui devrait tous
les 5 ans permettre d'avoir un véritable
débat sur les progrès réalisés sur les
les les difficultés qu'il convient
effectivement de surmonter et et sans
être la la grande loi autonomie dont
nous avions rêvé on pense qu'on s'en
approche un peu
euh même si elle sera très influencée
par l'aspect effectivement financier
alors que ce n'était pas peut-être le
rôle de de la grande loi dont nous
avions rêvé les uns et des autres si je
parle effectivement de de de de du
conseil de la CNSA de la même manière
les réflexions sur la tarification
forfaitaire par exemple pour le domicile
sont des réflexions qui nous intéressent
la la tarification horire je crois avoir
déjà dit compris devant vous d'ailleurs
tout le mal que je pensais de certains
aspects de la loi sur euh le le le le
euh le tarif plancher euh alors que
l'idée était une bonne idée mais le fait
que la compensation a été indifférenciée
euh pour euh selon les départements et
que on se rend compte que parmi les
départements ce sont beaucoup de
départements qui sont considérés comme
parmi les plus aisés pour ne pas dire
les plus riches qui bénéficient d'une
sorte d'effet deobè sur cette
compensation et puis cette c c cette euh
grille effectivement horaire euh évite
empêche d'avoir une autonomie euh telle
qu'on la souhaiterait pour les
personnels qui organise peuvent
organiser le le emploi du temps auprès
des personnes âgées et à donner
effectivement davantage de sens à ces
métiers qui sont des métiers aujourd'hui
encore très délaissés même s'il y a eu
des efforts réalisés sur le plan sur le
plan financier de de de de la même façon
nous nous apprécions les
euh euh le fléchage qui a été fait sur
les bénéfices des épades commerciaux
j'aiévoqué ce sujet il y a un instant il
me semblerait effectivement qu'il soit
encore très largement nécessaire de
renforcer un certain nombre de contrôles
et c'est peut-être l'occasion de dire
que les contrôle systématique sur
l'intégralité des épades avait laissé un
peu dubitatif les les membres du conseil
de la CNSA qui estimaient qu'il e mieux
valu avoir des des des procédures
d'alerte et des procédures de contrôle
inop là où il y avait alerte pour que le
contrôle soit plus approfondi je me suis
par exemple renseigné sur les problèmes
d'emra puisque c'est c'est un groupe qui
aujourd'hui attire un certain nombre de
remarques qui sont des remarques qui
ressemblent à s méprendre à ce qui était
reproché effectivement à l'époque à Orpa
et les les des structures d'emra qui
sont l'objet aujourd'hui de vive
critique avait fait l'objet de contrôle
ce qui veut donc dire que il n'y a pas
automaticité entre les contrôles et puis
euh la la la le fait que la situation
redevienne une situation euh classique
dire également que nous nous avons euh
nous apprécions le fait que il y ait un
intérêt qui soit porté aux résiden
autonomie c'est euh la résidence
autonomie nous paraît être l'une des
clés du logement des personnes euh âgées
euh dans dans dans cette volonté de
créer des des solutions intermédiaires
entre le domicile traditionnel euh et
lespad il y a bien sûr le logement
partagé il y a bien sûr le logement
inclusif mais il y a aussi la résidence
autonomie or les résidences autonomie
elles souffrent considérablement du fait
de ne pas avoir été entretenu d'une
manière convenable depuis des années et
elles ont besoin de de de d'être très
largement réhabilité ce qui exigera
également des crédits importants il y a
des crédits qui existent aujourd'hui et
qui sont utilisés mais qui ne sont pas à
la à la hauteur du problème euh de de de
de la même manière la résidence
autonomie présente également l'intérêt
de de pou pouvoir avoir une appréhension
domiciliaire plus importante que
certains éepad où vous avez
effectivement un nombre considérable de
personnes qui sont soit en fin de vie
soit en situation de très grande
dépendance donc il y a toute une série
de sujets qui sont des sujets sur
lesquels la CNSA est est totalement en
accord avec les propositions qui sont
faites elle souhaiterait que tout cela
puisse faire l'objet d'une globalisation
et d'une mise en cohérence et je reviens
sur ce sur i je commençais
que on est davantage un regard qui soit
un regard global sur le problème de de
de de de l'autonomie et de la dépendance
qu'il s'agisse des personnes âgées ou
qu'il s'agisse des personnes en
situation de handicap je veux pas être
plus long je préférrais répondre à vos
question merci monsieur le Président
Madame la
Directrice merci beaucoup je vais venir
pour ma part sur la question de
l'articulation entre entre cette
proposition de loi et la feuille de
route de la CNSA qui est constituée par
sa convention d'objectifs et de gestion
2022-2026 dont nous avions déjà parlé
lors de le le l'audition préparant vos
travaux autour de du projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 je veux souligner que dans cette
proposition de
loi viennent être conforté des action
importantes prévu par la coche de la
CNSA qui trouve de la sorte ou qui vont
trouver euh une une base législative qui
pourrait être très aidante en
particulier donc deux dispositions qui
pour l'une figurit dans le texte initial
et pour l'autre sont issu d'un d'un
amendement largement adopté qui concerne
d'une part le renforcement de la
prévention de la perte d'autonomie avec
la création d'une conférence nationale
et d'autre
part la création et la programmation de
la création de ce service départemental
euh de euh de l'autonomie euh s'agissant
de la prévention de la perte d'autonomie
l'article premer de la proposition de
loi donc prévoit la la création d'une
conférence nationale de l'autonomie qui
a vooccation assurer le le pilotage
national de cette politique prenant
appui sur un centre de ressources et de
preuve la la rédaction actuelle de de la
PPL parle de centre de preuve de pré de
prévention de économie gérée par la
CNSA et
donc cette cette disposition donc vient
conforter prolonger d'une part les la
création
ou la la consolidation de la politique
de prévention de la perte d'autonomie
qui avait été initié au travers de la
loi d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement qui a j'allais dire créé
l'instance territoriale de coordination
des actions de prévention avec les
conférences des financeurs prévention de
la perte d'autonomie mais sans poser une
gouvernance
nationale dans dans la loi donc en
l'absence de ces
dispositions j'allais dire les têtes de
réseau des parties prenantes des
conférences des financeurs se sont
organisé et la CNSA participe d'un COPIL
national de prévention la perte
d'autonomie qui
associe l'assurance vieillesse les
cararsad représentant des départements
euh mais cette instance a une vocation
j'allais dire technique de coordonner la
manière dont les uns et les autres euh
soutenant les acteurs territoriaux des
conférences euh euh des conférences euh
c'est une instance qui a permis de
coordonner euh euh nos actions euh qui a
permis de de de de de de poser les bases
d'un outillage euh homogène des
conférences en proposant des méthodes de
euh définition de programmes concertés
de prévention de la perte d'autonomie en
proposant des outils euh d'évaluation
euh des euh des proposition des
opérateurs euh mais euh il ne s'agit pas
et il ne pouvait pas s'agir par sa
composition d'une réelle instance de
pilotage de la politique de prévention
de la perte d'autonomie donc nous
accueillons vraiment avec beaucoup de
euh de de de de d'optimisme la la
création de cette de cette instance qui
euh dépasse aussi il faut le dire le
champ de compétence de la CNSA puisque
la politique de prévention c'est une
politique qui signneici très tôt et donc
il importe que puisse être présent dans
cette conférence les acteurs de
prévention de la santé au sens au sens
large dans le même temps cette
disposition elle reconnaît donc le rôle
du centre de ressources etpreuv qui est
une un chantier phare de la coche de la
CNSA qui a été été installé j'en avais
rendu compte lors de l'audition dans la
fin de l'année 22 qui a constitué sa
gouvernance dans l'année 23 défin son
programme de travail commencer de
recruter
nouer des actions de partenariat en
particulier avec les gérontopoles qui se
sont également renforcés et structurés
sur la même période qui démarre son
action d'animation des conférences de
renforcement de la culture de la preuve
de qui a pour vocation donc à la fois à
capitaliser sur les démarches probantes
à essmer ces démarches dans des dans un
dans un format accessible et à à
soutenir la culture de la prévention
dans les territoires je le redis pour
favoriser la mise en place d'action
réellement probante en matière de
prévention de la perte d'autonomie donc
la reconnaissance de ce rôle du centre
de ressources épreuve en sous soutien à
la au
futur à la future conférence nationale
nous semble de très bonne àoi je me
permets simplement de de signaler que la
rédaction actuelle en revanche des des
compétences à la fois de la de la
conférence et du du centre de ressources
épreuve s'agissant de la proposition
qu'il puisse
labellliser
des des des aides
techniques nous interroge en tout cas il
y a un décalage entre la manière dont le
centre de ressources et de preuve a été
imaginé dans le cadre de la coge la
manière dont il
est organisé staffé avec 3 ETP et
dimensionné en terme de ressources avec
cette mission de de de
labellisation qui nous semble assez
étrangère au champ des responsabilités
actuelles de la CNSA qui s'appuie plutôt
sur
qui aurait vocation à s'appuyer sur
d'autres instances ou ou organismes en
particulier la Commission nationale
d'évaluation des dispositifs médicaux et
des technologies de santé de la HS ou
bien d'autres organismes certificateurs
il nous semble que cette cette action de
la belllisation peut représenter une
charge extrêmement importante au regard
des de du très grand nombre d'aides
techniques qu'on évalue à plusieurs
milliers qui auraiit voocation ont
potentiellement être labellisé que leur
cette labelllisation donc impliquerait
de mobiliser des des ressources
conséquentes que nous estimons
possiblement à à plus d'une trentaine de
TP et donc voilà on on ne se sent pas
complètement armé ni en terme de
compétence ni en terme de légitimité
pour assumer ce type de fonction la
deuxième disposition qui
faitch et permet de conforter nous
donner une nouvelle ambition à des
chantiers prévus par la convention
d'objectif et de gestion c'est la
disposition importante relative à la
création d'un d'un service public
départemental
euh dédié donc au aux personnes âgées en
situation de
handicap ce spda ou SPTA suivant euh les
réflexions assez directement issues des
propositions du rapport de Dominique
Libau euh visant à installer dans les
territoires une instance un guichet
unique qui permette euh d'informer
d'orienter d'accompagner à la mise en
œuvre des droits les personnes et en
même temps de soutenir leurs aidanss et
promouvoir euh justement des actions de
de prévention euh de de la perte
d'autonomie donc le fait de donner euh
de proposer une base législative euh à
cette instance nous paraît également de
nature à à conforter euh euh l'action de
de la caisse qui dans le cadre de sa
coche avait vocation à soutenir
l'émergence de ce spda il est assez
évident que la base législative qui
prévoit la généralisation du du spda
sera sera naturellement déterminante
pour
favoriser la
mobilisation dans l'ensemble des
territoires des des acteurs composant ce
ce spda la définition
actuelle qui rejoint assez largement les
les le les quatre blocs de mission du
rapport Libo euh voilà et euh et est
bienvenue et pertinente et la CNSA je
voulais le souligner est d'ors et déjà
très mobilisé pour préparer et soutenir
la création de ce futur service public
départemental vous savez qu'un comité
d'orientation et de suivi a été mis en
place pour accompagner la préfiguration
de cespda la CNSA a
lancé sous l'égide de de la ministre
berger un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt l'été dernier pour inviter les
territoires qui souhaiteraient déjà se
placer en en préfiguration de ce spda à
se manifester pour que nous les
soutenions et que nous puissions
concevoir avec eux le futur cahier des
charge de ce spda il me semble que le
fait que les travaux aent démarrés de la
sorte et de nature à garantir euh une
bonne effectivité à la disposition
législative lorsqu'elle sera lorsqu'elle
sera votée et à accélérer et faciliter
sa mise en œuvre et son
opérationnalisation donc c'est ces deux
ces deux articles création du spda d'un
côté
création de la Conférence nationale de
l'autonomie reconnaissance de du du rôle
du centre de ressources et preuve sont
je le redis font écho à des chantien
important de de la COG et la CNSA sera
évidemment en capacité de de de
s'investir pleinement dans leur mise en
œuvre opérationnelle euh dans les autres
dispositions de de la proposition de de
loi je soulligne une petite
disposition qui reconnaî
euh également à la caisse un nouveau
rôle en terme de promotion de de l'audit
et du contrôle interne en direction des
réseaux de la caisse je mets un
guillemets des guillemets à autour de
cette expression et en particulier des
maisons départementales de la perte
d'autonomie
euh en faisant là encore un lien avec
notre coche puisque
euh vous savez que au cœur de la
création de la branche il y a cet
objectif de renforcer l'équité de
traitement euh euh des personnes dans
les territoires cette équité de
traitement se conçoit et se soutient par
un très grand nombre euh de dispositifs
et d'actions dont je vous avais exposé
que je vous avais exposé lors de
l'audition en particulier les travaux
d'outillage des professionnels des MDPH
le développement de système
d'information qui puisse être commun ou
harmonisé le travail autour de la
promotion de référentiel il nous semble
important de pouvoir non seulement
proposer ces outils mais nous assurer
qu'ils sont pleinement mobilisés par les
acteurs territoriaux la démarche de
contrôle interne elle a exactement cet
objet s'assurer que les référentiels
sont bien appropriés et nous semble
important de pouvoir inscrire cette
dimension de contrôle interne dans dans
la loi et puis s'agissant des des
mesures qui sont nouvelles et qui
pourrait appeler
pour trouver une traduction
opérationnelle qui pourrait appeler des
évolutions de de la coge ou une place
plus importante dans la feuille de route
plurannuelle de la de la CNSA il y a
d'abord bien sûr le le vote d'une loi de
programmation qu'a évoqué le président
lecer la cesra sera devrait être
mobilisée par la préparation de cette
loi et puis devrait surtout
naturellement être impliqué par sa mise
en œuvre donc voilà c'est il s'agit
encore d'une d'une perspective mais il
est clair que son adoption pourrait
conduire à à faire varier la trajectoire
financière de de la branche et il
pourrait appeler un avenant la coge sont
sont également euh
prévu par par la PPL euh une
expérimentation de dotation forfaitair
pour les services d'aide à domissile en
remplacement des des tarifs horaires
d'ors et déjà la la CNSA est mobilisée
par plusieurs réformes qui vise à
conforter le la capacité des services à
domicile à à garantir le fait pour les
personnes de rester chez elles je pense
aux réformes tarifaires qui sont qui
sont actuellement en Phe de de monter en
charge pour soutenir à la fois le
financement des services d'aide et
d'accompagnement à domicile et pour
soutenir le le bon fonctionnement des
Siad donc on en avait également parlé
lors de l'audition de l'automne donc la
CNSA est mobilisé sur le soutien à la
mise en uvre de sa de ces réformes leur
financement d'une part l'outillage des
autorités de tarification et de contrôle
pour s'emparer de ces nouveaux outils et
puis l'appui aux RS et au conseils
départementaux dans la fusion des
services autonomie à domicile voilà il
s'agira d'une nouvelle expérimentation
euh si euh si ce si cette
expérimentation de dotation forfaitaire
est adoptée sur lequel il incombera de
se mobiliser euh ce n'était pas prévu
par la COG
euh de manière complémentaire voilà
l'aide au soutien la mobilité des
professionnel à domicile ou le travail
sur les taux d'encadrement sont des
dispositions euh nouvelles qui
appelleront euh une une mobilisation de
la caisse qui euh euh qui ont des des
chantiers
nouveaux merci Madame la Directrice je
vais maintenant donner la la parole à
nos deux rapporteurs corrapporteur je
commence par Jean
sol monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice sur la
création du service public départemental
de de l'autonomie pensez-vous qu'il
permette de de réaliser l'objectif de la
mise en place de de guichet unique par
département tant entendu et surtout de
FA faité des démarches administratives
d'accompagnement et de suivi des
parcours des personnes âgées ou en
situation de de handicap où en est le
chantier de de préfiguration de ce SdPA
puisque nous avons compris qu'il y avait
un chantier de préfiguration qui a été
lancé a priori sans attendre l'adoption
de la proposition de
loi par ailleurs sur la Conférence
nationale de l'autonomie quelle serait
la répartition des rôles entre ces
instances et le conseil de la de la de
la
CNSA le texte confie par ailleurs à la
CNSA une mission nationale d'audit et et
d'évaluation des départements et des
MDPH vous l'avez dit en tant qu'acteur
des politiques de soutien à l'autonomie
des personnes âgées et des personnes
handicapées il introduit notamment pour
les départements et les MDPH de
communiquer à la CNSA tous les documents
et renseignements utiles et d'autoriser
la tenue de missions sur place ces
dispositions sont de nature selon vous à
facilité le travail de coordination et
d'animation de la CNSA auront-elles
selon vous pour effet de changer la
nature des relations entre les la CNSA
et les départements qui ne semblent pas
être en tout cas éterrogés enfin qui
semble plutôt être hétérogène dans les
départements en France enfin euh plus
généralement le texte contient-il selon
vous de réelles avancées dans le domaine
de la prévention en tout cas de la
prévention de la perte d'autonomie
puisque nous sommes bien sur ce sujetl
merci merci euh qui commence
président oui de deux mots et puis je
laisserai Madame la Directrice compléter
sur la la la mise en œuvre effectivement
du spda qui n'a pas
attendu le vote de la loi on est pour le
moment dans dans dans dans une procédure
dans un processus de préfiguration donc
on a fait appel à candidature au niveau
des départements il y a je crois 16
départements qui a seront retenus
effectivement pour cette préfiguration
qui ils vont être aidés par euh la CNSA
euh qu' va leur financer un équivalent
temp plein d'ailleurs pour coordonner un
petit peu ce travail de préfiguration
sur le territoire départemental l'état
souhaitait absolument mais je crois que
ça n'a pas pu être totalement réalisé
que toutes les régions soient par
département interposés représentés mais
on y est presque je crois euh et le le
le l'un l'une des utilités que nous
recherchons c'est parvenir à davantage
de
d'uniformité à davantage de comment dire
pour de avec ces personnes
d'universalité sur les les les les les
les aides qui seront accordés aux uns et
aux autres en fonction de leurs besoins
là on se heurte effectivement à un
problème que vous avez évoqué aussi dans
dans dans dans l'autre question c'est le
fait que nos services extérieurs ce sont
les ARS et les départements si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi et que les politiques
départementales sont des politiques
effectivement quel quelque fois très
disparate et et où nous voulons
absolument éviter que dans ce pays on en
vienne à choisir à un certain âge son
lieu d'habitation en fonction
effectivement des politiques qui sont
générées au niveau départemental
alors le développement comme le disait
Virginie manant le développement
effectivement des des des des des des
des systèmes d'information comme le CSAP
pas par exemple permet aussi de lisser
le
le le manque d'équité qui pouvait
exister il n'en paraisse pas moins que
que le service public départemental de
l'autonomie sera un instrument très fort
pour parvenir non pas à une uniformité
totale des politiques qui seront mis en
œuvre mais pour pour parvenir au fait
que globalement les personnes ayant les
mêmes problèmes se retrouvent aider
d'une manière qui soit une manière
équivalente c'est aussi l'opportunité de
de de de gérer de nouvelles relations
entre les ARS et puis les départements
parce que les relations n'étaient pas
extraordinaires entre les départements
et la CNSA puisque ils avaient quand
même très largement boycotté les
conseils de la CNSA lors du précédent
mandat mais les relations avec less
c'est également fort difficile moi je
quand j'ai pris la tête du département
du Nord en 2015 on se parlait pas entre
l'ARS et le département bon covid étant
passé par là on a accompli des progrès
tout à fait considérables aujourd'hui il
importerait que ce dialogue se fasse et
la CNSA peut mettre une goutte d'huile
dans les rouages se fe globalement ARS
département et et puis CNSA ceci
dit surtout n'abordons jamais de trop
près le problème du contrôle de de la
CNSA sur les politiques départementales
parce que là c'est c'est c'est un sujet
totalement explosif c'estàdire que si on
parlait de tutelle de de la CNSA sur un
département j'imagine déjà quelques-uns
de mes anciens collègues montant
immédiatement au créneau alors que il
est peut-être plus facile pour des
structures qui sont des
structures plus plus plus comment dire
où l'État joue davantage son rôle ou les
pouvoirs publics jouent d'avantage le
rôle de de d'intervenir et la CNSA si
elle peut jouer un rôle de bons offices
entre les uns et des autres elle le fera
très volontiers souvent on obtient des
résultats parce que on dit vous êtes
l'état sans être tout à fait l'état donc
il est plus facile effectivement
peut-être de travailler lorsque vous
voulez nous y aider on a des exemples si
vous voulez comme les les les les aides
qui sont accordées par exemple par la
CNSA au MDPH les plus en difficulté où
les choses se passent bien et et ou
barfou on est très surpris de voir des
départements extrêmement importants je
ne diraiis pas lesquels qui viennent
solliciter l'aide de de de de la la CNSA
ou une mission de la CNSA auprès de de
leur MDPH de la même façon notre notre
volonté c'est une volonté de bons office
et non pas une volonté qui a puisse être
résumée par le contrôle mais Virginie je
vous laisse
poursuivre
euh pour pour poursuivre précisément sur
sur la la disposition
législative visant à à soutenir la
capacité donc d'une mission d'appui et
d'évaluation de la qualité euh la
capacité donc à à réaliser non seulement
de l'accompagnement mais aussi du
conseil de l'audit et d'évaluation de de
l'ensemble des services autonomie euh je
veux dire que cette disposition nous
semble importante non pas pour euh
bouleverser le sens de la relation entre
la CNSA et les services des conseils
départementaux et des MDPH le président
leer vient de rappeler hein que
le la le positionnement de de la CNSA
vis-à-vis de de ces services euh sur
lequel nous n'avons absolument aucun
lien hier archique ou d'autorité est un
positionnement qui s'est nourri dans
l'histoire d'un travail
d'animation de coconstruction de
référentiel et sur la période plus
récente notamment avec la feuille de
route mdphh 22 d'une capacité à
constituer une mission d'accompagnement
qui intervienent en proximité des MDPH
en difficulté en particulier nous avons
cette mission sur les deux dernières
années à accompagner une vingtaine de
MDPH à
rétablir leur leur délai de de
traitement qui s'était dégradé pour des
des raisons diverses et à à à à
concevoir et mettre en œuvre des plans
d'amélioration de la qualité qui
permettent je le redis non seulement de
réduire les délis de traitements mais de
les réduire durablement en revisitant
les processus d'instruction des des
demandes et les processus de délivrance
des droits c'est une mission qui qui qui
a fonctionné avec succès je pense au
département du du à la MDPH du
finisterire dont les délais de
traitement étai en moyenne de plus de 6
mois et qui ont été divisés par deux de
à l'
MDPH de de laine dont les les
rétablissements le rétablissement a été
aussi spectaculaire voilà donc cette
mission de d'accompagnement elle est
utile pour autant et je le redis dans le
contexte de création d'une branche de la
sécurité sociale dont les comptes sont
désormais certifiés il il importe et la
Cour des comptes vrant en qualité de de
certificateur le demande que nous
puissions garantir l'ouverture des
justes droits et un une dimension de
contrôle interne qui dépasse j'allais
dire le périmètre strict du
fonctionnement de la caisse nationale
mais qui
étend la prise en compte du
fonctionnement des services qui
aujourd'hui
œuvre très concrètement pour ouvrir les
droits je pense en particulier au mdphh
dont les CDAPH vont ouvrir les droits à
prestations individuelles ou aux
accompagnements collectifs pour
lorsqu'ell orientent vers des
établissements et services et donc il
s'agit d'une mission qui est très
directement liée à la création de la
branche à la certification de ces
comptes globaux et qui vise à renforcer
vis-à-vis du certificateur notre
capacité à garantir euh la parfaite
conformité
de de de l'ensemble des des des des
ouvertures de droit qui sont soutenu par
les financements de la branche euh au à
un ensemble de de référentiels donc il
nous semble et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la création de cette mission
d'audit et de et de conformité a été euh
est déjà inscrite dans la coche de la
CNSA il nous semble que nous pouvons en
même temps continuer d'avoir un un
travail d'expertise d'animation euh de
promotion de la coconstruction avec les
MDPH et les services autonomie tout en
étant capacité de nous doter d'une de
d'une d'une compétence d'audit qui
permettra de réaliser aussi bien des
audits thématiques sur l'attribution de
certaines prestations par exemple donc
des a dit qui ne conduisent pas à à à à
à à regarder tout le fonctionnement des
MDPH par exemple mais de s'appuyer sur
plusieurs d'entre elles pour
identifier par exemple et la manière
dont elle don dont dont est ouvert le
droit à la PCH vous savez que c'est une
prestation complexe il nous paraît
intéressant de pouvoir regarder très
concrètement et de très près sur quel de
quelle manière les les équipes
travaillent voilà de pouvoir réaliser
ces ces ces actions nous semblent de
nature d'une part à répondre aux
attentes du certificateur je le redis et
à conforter notre capacité
d'accompagner j'allais dire au plus près
du fonctionnement des équipes leur
travail d'évaluation d'instruction et
ainsi de garantir l'équité dans
l'évaluation des situations
individuelles pour revenir pardon sans
être trop longue sur sur le spda donc je
vous confirme qu'un travail de de
préfiguration est en cours que un appel
à manifestation d'intérêt a été lancé et
que dont les résultats devraient pouvoir
être annoncés prochainement et les les
la ministre Berger a annoncé qu'elle
enfin qu'elle ferait l'annonce de de ces
départements retenus la durant l'année
24 la CNS a voocation à travaillé de
deux manières
sur des outils de nature à favoriser le
développement de ce guichet unique donc
à soutenir les préfigurateurs dans leur
démarche de préfiguration précisément de
ce ce ce ce service et d'autre part et
avec eux en sorte de disposer d'outils
qui soi je leuris coconstruit avec les
territoires c'est l'ADN de la méthode de
fonctionnement de la CNSA de construire
des outils qui aideront les autres
départements à structurer un tel guicher
vous m'interrogiez sur l'apport de ce
service aux personnes je veux le redire
he le constat de Dominique Libau mais
qui est aussi un constat qui est fait à
la CNSA par le Conseil le constat c'est
celui de ce que les démarches
administrative qu'on à à à faire les
personnes âgées mais aussi les personnes
en situation du handicap ça parente
encore trop souvent les personnes nous
le disent elles-même un parcours du
combattant vers qui se tourner pour
obtenir quel droit une fois qu'on a un
droit qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait toutes ces démarches sont trop
complexes et il importe de
pouvoir fédérer une coordination
d'acteurs qui aujourd'hui existe dans
les territoires il y a des points
d'infoservice des clics euh des
CCAS des services polyvalents de
conseils départementaux les MDPH on l'a
dit des dispositifs d'appui à la
coordination qui travaille qui apporte
un service mais dont la lisibilité est
loin d'être garantie
donc ou pas ou pas assez ou pas assez
étroitement donc c'est pour franchir
cette marche de la qualité de
l'intégration qui est prévue cette
disposition et voilà nous sommes déjà en
train de de travailler à à à faire en
sorte que cette disposition puisse être
utile pour les
personnes merci Madame la Directrice je
donne maintenant la parole à Justin
guidez merci je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses quand même qui ont été dites
moi je vais simplement revenir sur
certaines choses la proposition de la
programmation pluriannuelle je crois que
ça c'est énormément de demandé et ça
sera apprécié parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui i on a quand même pas de
de vu que qui paye quoi voilà je veux
dire on a quand même du mal à savoir qui
va payer quand même toutes ces
propositions et cetera je vourais savoir
si aujourd'hui vous connaissez à quelle
hauteur la CNSA contribuerait-elle au
financement des dépenses liées à la
coordination du spda et au
fonctionnement de la commission des
financeurs dans le cadre de la
conférence territoriale de l'autonomie
les concours de la CNSA au titre des
dépenses décidées par cette commission
des financeurs ont-ils vocation a
progressé deè question l'article 1er bis
C qui prévoit la transmission par les
départements de la CNSA de données
relatives au nombre de financement du
projet péren vous semble-t-il
applicable en ce qui concerne l'accueil
des résidents comment appréciez-vous la
proposition de réserver une fraction des
bénéfices réalisés par les épades privé
lucratif pour financer des actions en
faveur des de l'amélioration des
conditions d'hébergement et d'accueil
des résidents je vrais revenir a aussi
sur les contrôles c'est vrai qu'on parle
pratiquement que des contrôles
importants dans les éepads mais on parle
pas du tout des contrôles dans les
établissement de personnes handicapées
alors même si on me dit mais si ça en
fait partie aussi n'empêche que l'on
parle aujourd'hui que des éepades donc
moi j'aimerais bien que ça soit renforcé
aussi au niveau des établissements pour
personnes handicapées et puis mes deux
dernières questions existe-t-il
actuellement des possibilités de
financement des services d'aide et
d'accompagnement à domicile sous forme
de dotation globale et et quells sont
les limites des possibilités existantes
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez par
rapport à ça et quels sont les objectifs
des expérimentations prévues à l'article
8 celle-ci vous semble-t-elle de nature
améliorer le financement des services à
domicile voilà je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président
oui quelques quelques éléments de
réponse sur les les
contrôles j'accueille avec satisfaction
votre remarque consistant à dire
effectivement qu'il faut une apprhension
global euh sur le grand âge et sur le
handicap peut-être qu'aujourd'hui que
jusqu'à présent les les les les les euh
dériv étaient plus importante dans le
secteur du grand âge mais j'en nul ne
peut l'affirmer effectivement d'une
manière euh totalement euh assuré je
signale également que sur le handicap
vous avez euh d'autres problèmes qui se
posent comme le fait que des des États
voisins comme la Belgique par exemple
ont acquis une certaine pratique et une
certaine compétence sur qu'il faut
certes contrôler mais qui rend très
difficile d'interrompre de manière
brutale la collaboration qu'elle pouvait
avoir jusqu'à présent et qui impose
effectivement de revaloriser les
entreprises qui sont qui travaillent
bien qui sont situés à l'étranger de la
même manière qu'on le fait pour les pour
les entreprises françaises aujourd'hui
on a on a pas pas vraiment le choix sur
la dotation globale sur l'aide à
domicile je crois que tous les éléments
de réflexion sont importants le secteur
de l'aide à domicile est un secteur qui
est aujourd'hui dans une situation
d'extrême difficulté alors qu'il n'a
jamais été aussi indispensable donc il y
a sur ce point des efforts à faire qui
sont des efforts colossaux aussi bien
d'ailleurs sur la la reconnaissance
reconnaissance au sens littéral du terme
reconnaissance financière que sur le le
le le le l'attractivité de de la
fonction attractivité de la fonction sur
lequel il y a des éléments d'ailleurs
mais il compris dans la PPL au niveau de
l'aide à la mobilité pour ces personnels
la prise en charge par la CNSA ou par
l'État ou par les départements ou de
manière groupé par les uns et par les
autres de de de
de la mise de la mise en place par
exemple de de de de flotte de véhicules
ou les aides qui sont données à
l'acquisition de véhicules la
possibilité d'utiliser ces véhicules en
dehors même de leur travail mais pour
conduire leurs enfant à l'école ou pour
faire leurs courses sont des éléments
d'atractivité supplémentaire et puis il
y a le véritable sens à donner
effectivement à ces fonction je crois
que une réforme qui va rentrer en
application au 1er janvier donc c'est
demain va y contribuer ce sont les
fameuses heur ex de convivialité devenu
heure de lien social qui vont permettre
effectivement que ces personnes soient
soient rémunérées pas seulement pour le
temps qu'elle passe à faire la toilette
à préparer le repas à donner le repas
mais aussi le temps qu'elle passe pour
parler avec la personne la personne
notamment la personne âgée la personne
en situation de Grand Handicap elles ont
effectivement un besoin de s'exprimer de
de de de de de pouvoir effectivement
échanger sur la la leur famille sur leur
quartier sur leurs village selon qu'ells
sont en milieu urbain ou en milieu rural
tout cela ce sont des éléments qui a
doivent être effectivement pris
euh pris en compte de de de de de
manière importante mais on est très très
loin si vous voulez de des souhaits qui
avaient été exprimés dans différents
rapports comme le rapport je crois de
madamel comomer qui a disait que d'ici
2025 il fallait créer 350000 emplois de
de d'accompagnement et du soin on y
parviendra jamais d'où le fait que à
côté des aides à domicile il faut aussi
être extrêmement vigilant sur les aidans
les aidents qui représentent environ 8
millions de de de personnes d'après les
chiffres très approximatifs qui nous
sont anné sur lesquels il y a aussi
quelques progrès qui ont été réalisés
mais où ces progrès ne sont pas
suffisants et il faut aussi une
appréhension différente au niveau de de
de de de l'état de la CNSA mais aussi et
surtout des départements sur ce que l'on
appellera la la capacité d'accorder du
répi aux personnes proches et aux
personnes aidantes hein moi j'ai toute
une série effectivement de de de de de
protestations qui sont faites par les
territoires devant des initiatives très
riches consistant à mettre en place des
structures d'accueil à à la fois pour
aidant et aider de façon à ce que la
solution ça ne soit pas toujours de
mettre l'aider pour 15 jours ou pour 3
semaines dans un épad mais de pouvoir
prendre ensemble les le repos nécessaire
et qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
encouragés comme ces solutions devrai
l'être y compris au niveau effectivement
territorial je vous laisse compléter
madame directrice peut-être JEE sur sur
deux point d'abord sur la mobilisation
des des financements de de la branche
autonomie mis en soutien au aux actions
de prévention pour rappeler deux choses
d'une part que les les les financements
dédiés à la prévention de la perte
d'autonomie sur la période 2022-226 donc
dans le cadre de la coche son très
significatif la branche a prévu de
mobiliser 1 milliard d'euros sur
l'ensemble de cette période pour
soutenir les actions pilotées au
territorial par les conférences déf
financeur c'est une trajectoire j'allais
dire ascendante puisque les crédits
dévoluent donc au conférence des
financeurs progresse chaque année de de
la coche vont progresser en 2024 et que
par l'intermédiaire de ces financements
donc de concours que vous connaissez
bien madame la sénatrice pour avoir
travaillé à l'élargissement de l'UR
objet au soutiens aux aidents le
concours à la fois destiné à soutenir la
prévention en résidence autonomie et
puis puis les concours dédiés à soutenir
les autres actions de prévention donc en
particulier les actions collectives
représentent
aujourd'hui plus de 50 % des crédits
mobilisés par les par ces conférences
donc la CNSA et j'allais dire le premier
financeur la branche autonomie et le
premier financeur des actions de
prévention abstraction faite de l'accès
au au S techniques financé par
l'Assurance Maladie via la liste des
prestations et produits remboursables
donc nous occupons une place très
importante dans dans le financement de
cette prévention je le dis assez
simplement on n pas non plus moi j'ai
pas de en l'espèce je fais pas la la
course à la timbal si d'autres
financeurs et je sais que la COG de la
knnave lui permet également de renforcer
ses moyens dédiés à la prévention de la
perte d'autonomie au travers des crédits
d'Action Social mobilisé par les CARSAT
si l'assurance vieillesse peut
intervenir de manière accrue
sur la prévention évidemment que ce
renforcement de la la capacité
collective sera très bienvenu et si la
CNSA n'est plus le premier financeur
mais devient le deuxième financeur dans
le cadre d'un périmètre de financement
accru je crois que ce sera au bénéfice
des des personnes concernées euh sur le
le deuxième point sur lequel vous euh
vous nous interrogiez en en rebond sur
les propos du du président lecer la
question de l'expérimentation de ces
dotations forfaitaires je veux dire que
d'une certaine manière la réforme du
financement des Sades avec la mise en
place de la dotation complémentaire
permettait de euh j'allais dire de de
tracer le chemin d'une d'un financement
plus global des sad puisque la mise en
place de la
dotation
complémentaire est conditionnée par la
signature de ces pommes et donc au
travers des cespommes les satades sont
financés par une dotation globale qui
fait masse des crédits correspondants au
tarifs planchés qui sont des tarifs
horaires mais globalisés dans le cadre
du CPOM et de la dotation complémentaire
je crois que ce qui est
euh une avancée euh symbolique mais
importante de l'expérimentation de la
dotation forfaitaire c'est euh de de
d'ouvrir la perspective d'un financement
qui soit j'allais dire définitivement
euh distingué euh d'un financement hor
puisque je le redis le spom c'est
l'addition entre guillemets des tarifs
horaires multiplié par le nombre
d'heures prévisionnel cor avOcatiOn
assurer le Sade sur le territoire plus
une dotation complémentaire avec la
dotation forfaitaire on on change de
paradigme c'est peut-être un peu
ambitieux mais on se rapproche du
financement d'établissements et services
médicaux-saux classiques ou euh ce c'est
bien le le fonctionnement global de la
structure en direction d'une pluralité
euh de personnes accompagné qui est
financé par cette dotation et euh on
s'oriente vers l'abandon d'une référence
à une intervention horaire qui est c'est
vrai beaucoup dénoncé par les acteurs
comme euh allant de paire avec un
fractionnement des intervention une
difficulté à financer des temps de
coordination des temps qui ne se
mesurent pas strictement par la présence
auprès de la personne donc c'est une
nous semble-t-il une
avancée nous allons maintenant donner la
parole
à nos différents collègues et je vais
commencer par Corine
Ferré merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice beaucoup de choses ont été
dites à la fois dans votre présentation
mais aussi après les interrogations et
intervention de de mes collègues
rapporteurs pour autant je souhaitais
insister sur deux points trois peut-être
la première dire que comme vous je
partage le regret que vous avez exprimé
sur le fait qu'on a toujours pas cette
grande loi autonomie pourtant promise
depuis de nombreuses années et qui
aurait pris et qui devait prendre dans
son ensemble la problématique de la
prise en charge de l'autonomie des
personnes âgées notamment euh donc je je
voulais le le signaler je voudrais tout
d'abord revenir sur le le titre premier
qui concerne donc la création d'une
conférence nationale autonomie et euh la
mise en place aussi d'un service public
départemental autonomie cette conférence
nationale je voulais vous demander si
euh vous ne pensez pas qu'une conférence
ou des conférences territoriales auraiit
été plus pertinent pour être dans la
proximité d'une réponse ou de réponses
qui doivent être faites à nos aînés on
va dire et à tous les acteurs qui
interviennent dans ce domaine vous avez
mentionné effectivement euh dans nos
territoires ou territorialement il
existe des conférences de financeurs
mais donc euh comment trouver la bonne
articulation voir euh estce que cette
conférence nationale puisqu n pas
décliner territorialement est-ce qu'elle
ne va pas manquer ou est-ce que voilà
comment toutes les instances déjà
existantes trouveront toujours leur
pertinence pour répondre aux besoins et
le service public départemental de
l'autonomie vous l'avez rappelé c'est un
amendement du gouvernement qui a été
proposé enfin présenté au dernier moment
lors de l'examen de la loi mais qui fait
écho à une proposition de Dominique
Libau dans son second rapport donc c'est
extrêmement important mais voilà je je
voulais avoir aussi votre avis sur la
façon dont dont cette organisation là se
glisse dans dans cette proposition de
loi l'autre point porte sur le titre 3
et en particulier le titre 3 c'est le le
les conditions d'habitat les prestations
de qualité grâce à des professionnels
accompagnés je lis hein et soutenu dans
leur pratique considérez-vous que les
propositions qui sont formulées dans ce
titre 3 par les diff différents alinéas
et articles sont suffisants pour rendre
ces métiers attractifs vous l'avez dit
on manque cruellement de de personnes et
de de personnel j'ai envie de dire de de
de femmes lorsque nous avons auditionné
avec les rapporteur les représentants
des organisations syndicales
particulièrement de des salariés qui
interviennent à domicile ils ont
rappeler que le le le le nombre de
femmes 95 % de ces emplois sont occupé
par des femmes plus de 66 % d'entre
elles sont à temps partiel non choisies
donc tout ça ne ne rendre pas ne rend
pas ses métiers attractifs des
propositions sont faites vous l'avez
rappelé en matière de de mobilité
d'organisation de temps d'échange mais
où sont les moyens on nous dit il nous
disent que dans certaines structures ce
temps d'échange n'est pas applicable
parce que ce temps d'échange il est pas
financé donc voilà c'est un vrai
problème etc de la formation la
formation aussi de de ces femmes on va
dire HE puisqueelles sont très
majoritaires dans leurs interventions à
domicile notamment parce que elles ont
le sentiment parfois
euh faute de formation de de
connaissance et bien d'être maltraitante
et que la maltraitance elle existe dans
les établissements mais elle existe
aussi à domicile merci merci beaucoup la
parole à Corine
Ambert merci monsieur le Président euh
rapidement euh monsieur le Président
tout à l'heure alors c'est un peu en
marge du texte qui nous réunit ce matin
mais tout à l'heure j'ai cru comprendre
quand vous évoquez l'expérimentation sur
la fusion soin indépendance que alors
que le gouvernement avait annoncé au
plus 20 départements j'ai l'impression
si j'ai bien compris vos propos que ça
serait C qui serait retenu et que les
choses étaient déjà bouclées est-ce que
vous pouvez me confirmer ou pas mais
attendez je pose ma question puis après
voilà et plus particulièrement donc sur
le le texte bien vieillir euh l'accueil
familial l'accueil familial on en parle
peu il est pas
développé donc accueil familial vous le
savez agrément du président du conseil
départemental donc il est pas développé
de la même manière dans les différents
départements hein certains départements
est très développés d'autres c'est pas
le cas
euh la loi aujourd'hui les textes disent
que un accueillant familial peut-être
agréé pour trois personnes auou plus et
avec une dérogation du président du
conseil départemental si les conditions
le permettent l'accueillant familial
peut-être agréé pour quatre personnes
s'il accueille un couple je crois que
c'est ce que dit la loi aujourd'hui que
pensez-vous de l'accueil familial parce
que c'est une des solutions d'accueil
des personnes âgées d'ailleurs ou
handicapé puisque on a de tytes
d'accueil familial est-ce que vous
pensez que cette dérogation pourrait
être élargie à l'ensemble des
accueillants familiaux toujours si les
conditions d'accueil le permettent ou
pas parce que cont tenu du
vieillissement de la réticence à rentrer
en épad et cetera pourquoi pas un
accueil de de proximité euh avec
j'allais dire un atout même si le métier
est très difficile c'est qu'au moins il
y a un suivi par les services du conseil
départemental puisque qui dit agrément
dit suivi accompagnement alors qu'en
même temps on voit s'ouvrir des
structures d'accueil sans autorisation
des conseils départementaux de la
colocation et cetera qui échappe à tout
contrôle voilà je vous remercie merci
bien an minon
oui merci monsieur le Président euh tout
d'abord merci euh pour l'ensemble des
des communications que vous avez faites
monsieur le Président Madame les
directrice une une première observation
je vous ai écouté monsieur le Président
quand vous avez parlé des PPL en disant
que vous doutiez fort de l'avenir de ces
PPL
euh une observation on observe de plus
en plus la multiplication de ces PPL un
peu partout qui euh d'une manière ou
d'une autre exonère finalement le
gouvernement de faire des propres lois
ses propres lois et d'en faire des plus
profondes de plus approfondi ça c'est
une observation ma question est la
suivante j'ai assisté la semaine
dernière à une audition de nos
rapporteur qui
auditionnait des opérateurs privés l'un
de ces opérateurs privés a parlé du prix
de journée et il a dit que le prix de
journée pouvait varier entre 75 € si les
chiffres sont bons à 1500 € n'y a-t-il
pas dans ces conditions un risque de
voir certains tenter de trans former
leur épad en soins
palliatifs merci juste pour compléter
l'intervention d' Milon rappelons que
dans une ppel il y a ni étude d'impact
ni avis du Conseil d'État en plus voilà
monsieur le Président puis madame
oui sur le d'une part sur les les les 16
départements les 16 départements sont
des départements qui ont été choisis
pour l'expérimentation de de de service
public départemental de de l'autonomie
donc on est on est sur sur une donc une
une autre thématique sur l'accueil
familial l'accueil familial aujourd'hui
il existe de manière très homéopathique
si vous voulez hein euh le département
que j'ai présidé et le deuxè de de de de
de France en la matière derrière la
Réunion alors que le nombre de personnes
n'est pas considérable or il y a de vrai
succès dans l'accueil familial il y a
notamment un succès important de
l'accueil familial en milieu rural qu'on
avait rebaptisé l'accueil à la ferme euh
pour enjoliver un peu les choses qui se
passe très bien euh et je pense que il y
a il y a des opportunités qui existent
il y a des opportunités qui existent
aussi bien d'ailleurs pour les personnes
âgées que pour les personnes en
situation de handicap qui sont aussi des
opportunités dans dans quelquefois dans
le milieu agricole d'avoir une
diversification des responsabilités et
je constate que là où ça fonctionne bien
les personnes qui sont en accueil
familial généralement elles y restent
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de leur vie
c'est-à-dire avec le le le le le fait
que pour la plupart ell ne ne quittent
pas le le le le ce ce domicile qui qui
est devenu leur domicile pour les pad
mais qu'elles y restent globalement donc
c'est c'est un des points sur lesquels
il faut euh réfléchir au au
développement un peu comme comme comme
le logement partagé comme le logement
inclusif sont vraiment des des des des
des des modalités qui vont se développer
d'une manière qui doivent se développer
d'une manière tout à fait importante sur
la Conférence nationale et non pas
territoriale vous savez il y a il y a
tellement d'hypothèses euh aujourd'hui
en France où on a beaucoup de mal à
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un minimum de
de d'équité entre les situations des des
des des différents départements
euh j'ai été vice-président de la de
laadf en charge de de des finances j'ai
pu constater effectivement l'extrême
difficulté d'avoir des des décisions qui
soient des décisions écuméniques au
niveau de DF la DF il y a quelquefois
autant de décisions qu'il y a qu'il y a
de département que je je je je me dis
que sur le plan de de de d'aller vers
une plus grande universalité une plus
grande équité ce qui est quand même
notre responsabilité ça exige qu'il y
ait parfois des structures qui qui
soient des structures ayant compétences
au au niveau national je je n'ai pas dit
de mal mon cher Alain sur les PPL j'ai
quelquefois l'impression effectivement
que on a une PPL pour préparer la loi
c'est ce qui était pas exactement la la
la raison effectivement du droit
d'initiative parlementaire et puis bon
j'ai été battu à la chaîne même si je me
vende beaucoup d'avoir une PPL qui est
allé jusqu'au bout quand j'étais
sénateur le nombre de PPL qui
aboutissent C si celle-ci est très
particulière c'est c'est est assez
restreint le le
le la la discussion que vous allez avoir
sur la PPL elle est fondamentale sur un
certain nombre de sujets et je pense
qu'elle est fondamentale aussi sur ce
que sera l'avenir
au niveau de de de de des lois de de
financement et les lois de financement
qui devivront revenir tous les 5 ans si
j'ai bien compris et qui permettront
effectivement de de de de de mettre en
musique les les les décisions que que
vous aurait contribué à faire prendre
notre situation à la cadsa est un peu la
situation quelquefois du législateur qui
est sous les fourches codines de
l'article 40 c'est-à-dire que nous avons
effectivement des déclarations de de de
ministres depuis le vote de la coge qui
mett en place des politiques qui sont
des politiques totalement intéressantes
mais qui ont un coûte et au moment du
vote du budget on en est à tirer les
sonnettes en disant
euh madame la Première
ministre les les promesses ont été
faites il faut maintenant que les moyens
soient donnés effectivement à la CNSA de
tenir les promesses gouvernementales et
c'est c'est c'est je dis pas qu'on y
arrive pas mais c'est quelque fois un
petit peu compliqué et lorsque l'on
demande effectivement is les
possibilités d'AV de la coge qui sont
d'ailleurs prévu pourtant et qui devrait
être un phénomène totalement banal et
normal on a quelquefois l'impression de
de
proférer quelques insanités si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi mais on y arrivera
merci Monsieur Président je continue
voilà donc Monique
Lubin merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président j'ai
bien compris que la mise en place de ce
service public départemental de
l'autonomie conduirait enfin l'un des
l'un des vœux du du législateur c'est de
conduire à une certaine
uniformisation des services qui sont
proposés dans les départements et qui
qui peuvent être diverses et variés mais
au-delà est-ce que nous devons y voir
finalement une une territ une
terriorialisation je vais y arriver de
la 5e branche c'est un peu ce que je
crois madame la direec directrice nous a
expliqué ensuite moi j'ai j'ai une
inquiétude
euh uniformiser c'estes bien euh est-ce
que néanmoins les départements garderont
une certaine capacité d'innovation
euh il y a un certain nombre de
départements dans ce pays qui sont assez
innovants pour ce qui concerne l'accueil
des personnes âgées ou l'accueil des
aidanss donc est-ce qu'on continuera à
le est-ce qu'on leur laisse a toujours
cette possibilité cette liberté si je
vous pose cette question c'est parce que
je suis un peu inquiète et je suis très
minoritaire sur le sujet mais ce n'est
pas grave d'une certaine volonté me
semble-t-il de ramener la dépendance
vers les ARS et donc quelques part de
priver les départements d'une partie de
leurs compétences sur ce sur ce sujet
donc j'espère que les département
pourront garder leur les départements
pourront garder leur capacités
d'innovation ensuite ite concrètement
moi j'ai du mal à voir comment ce
service départemental va se mettre en
place est-ce qu'il s'agira d'un guichet
unique par département puisque le but
c'est d'informer les gens est-ce qu'il
s'agira d'un guichet unique qui
financera le fonctionnement de ce
guichet unique si ce sont les
collectivités qui doivent mettre à
disposition de ce guichet unique des
agents ça veut dire que ce sont les
collectivités qui vont financer est-ce
qu'on ne doit pas craindre que les se
passe comme elles se sont passées pour
d'autres services et notamment France
service où on voit petit à petit quand
même que pour maintenir les maisons
France service il faut que les
collectivités financent sinon le service
ne se maintient pas et enfin c'est plus
une remarque qu'une question moi ce que
je vois au travers de cette proposition
de loi je rejoins tout ce qui a été dit
hein sur le fait que du coup il y a pas
d'étude d'impact et on évite un certain
nombre comme ça de questions on n' pas à
y répondre et donc moi ce que je crains
c'est que là finalement cette PPL amène
à à à créer une instance ou des
instances supplémentaires mais qu'en
est-il de l'offre qu'en est-il de
l'offre moi quand je discute avec mes
concitoyens ils sont pas vraiment
inquiets de savoir où trouver
l'information même si c'est difficile je
l'entends bien pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux moi c'est plutôt de l'offre
donc je voudrais qu'on parle vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure les systèmes euh
portés par certains départements les
projets portés par certains départements
sur les aidés et les aidants le mien en
fait partie mais il y a d'autres projets
ailleurs je je et que nous avons
énormément de mal à faire financer que
nous avons énormément de mal à faire
percer si je puis dire au niveau de
l'État et du gouvernement donc ce qui
m'intéresse moi surtout c'est l'offre et
est-ce que cette PPL une fois votée
n'empêchera pas justement qu'on vienne à
une grande loi dépendance où on parlera
d'offre et de financement merci beaucoup
Olivier merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice pour la clarté de de vos
propos beaucoup de de choses ont été
exprimées effectivement je crois qu'il y
a une tension dialectique entre le
principe
d'uniformité et puis le le principe
d'équité et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
exprimé monsieur le Président en disant
il faudrait pas qu'à un moment donné en
fonction de son âge ont choisi tel ou
tel lieu de de de d'habitation en
fonction des services qui pourrait être
offert ou ou ou financer et compte tenu
du fait que on va rentrer dans une
période on est déjà après le quoi qu'il
en coûte dans une période de tension
financière tension financière pour les
épades tension financière pour les soins
à domicile et sans doute aussi tension
financière pour les les départements je
m'inquiète plus de la question de la
rupture d'équité territoriale or nous
sommes dans un état qui est un État
décentralisé et pas un État fédéral et
la question de de veiller à cette équité
territoriale moi je suis évidemment
partisan de la décentralisation et de
l'autonomie des départements mais dans
le cadre d'une
équité territoriale je il me semble que
et puis dans la 5è branche il va falloir
une légitimité très forte de la CNSA par
rapport à à ces à ces enjeux alors ma
question elle est un peu en marge parce
que bon la Conférence nationale j'avoue
que j'y vois les limites on est habitué
à ce genre de choses mais comment
voyez-vous les choses pour l'avenir pour
renforcer la la la légitimité de de la
CNSA dans le cadre de la 5e branche et
dans le cadre de cet enjeu de de de
d'équité territoriale je vous remercie
merci bien la parole à Jean-Marie
vonarenberg bien prononcé merci merci
monsieur le
président tu as bien dit oui c'est vrai
mais je n'en doutais pas bon monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice moi j'ai
deux questions sur l'organisation et sur
le financement euh je pourrais en avoir
beaucoup d'autres parce que c'est un
sujet un peu complexe on l'avoue et on
l'a entendu sur l'organisation euh je
pense que bon on a un cahier des charges
qui se qui fait référence au rapport
Libau sur la démarche à suivre euh je
dois dire j'ai j'ai entendu ce que vous
disiez monsieur le Président en parlant
d'universalité je crains qu'on ne
confonde universalité et
uniformité je sais que vous partagez
tout à fait mon point de vue il on été
président de département vous savez ce
que c'est mais je crains compte tenu de
la
centralité la CNSA de la Caisse
nationale euh qui n'est peu
décentralisé je crains que ça ça ne soit
pas effectif et que ce cahier des
charges il s'applique indifféremment
partout sur le territoire alors que il
me paraît essentiel et on l'a entendu
encore hier avec les rapporteurs de la
part de Monsieur Libau il est essentiel
de penser
territorialité ça peut être le
département d'ailleurs suivant la taille
du département ou ça peut être quelque
chose de plus petit d'ailleurs si on
fait référence à l'article bis de cette
PPL parle de groupements territoriaux
c'est aussi dans l'article un bis F les
services territoriaux je crois beaucoup
à ça l'essentiel étant qu'on crée qu'on
organise les services autour de la
personne autour de la personne qui est
une convention c'est d'ailleurs suggéré
dans l'article 8 B0 une convention entre
le département l'ARS ça répond peut-être
à certaines inquiétudes que j'ai entendu
se manifester tout à l'heure et
notamment à l'instant par Olivier euh
département l' RS et puis la structure
qui peut être une structure d'aide à
domicile ou un épad euh qui gère la
personne je crois que ça c'est un point
capital si on veut réussir euh
ce cette mutation on peut dire hein dans
les services aujourd'hui 2è point c'est
le financement ça a é évoqué par
certains bon on a deux aspects souvent
dans les épades en particulier euh santé
financé par la SCU et puis le social
financé par le
Département certains suggèrent de de
scinder euh ces euh cela de donner euh
de une responsabilité du financement
uniquement pour le social département
puis la santé à la SC de mainten alors
où est la cohérence
quand on aura effectivement le besoin
effectivement de notamment dans le
service d'aide à domicile de mettre en
place ce qui est en train de se produire
dans pas mal de structures de mettre en
place des équipes autonome de soignants
d'aide à domicile qui fonctionne en
groupe et qui auraiit effectivement
àinder leur
temps parce qu'il ser il relver de la
sécurité sociale pour ce qui concerne le
soin ou de
la du département quand il s'agit
d'accompagnement effectivement de la
personne je pense qu'il faut trouver là
à revoir complètement le financement
alors peut-être que la solution est dans
le
forfait mais ça reste quand même tout à
fait à démontrer voilà merci beaucoup
Corine
Bier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice je vouserci merci pour vos
interventions je souhaite en faire deux
moi la première vous y avez déjà
partiellement répondu mais il est
important de s'y attarder j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer la semaine
dernière une association qui œuvre dans
le service à domicile il m'ont alerté
sur plusieurs difficultés qu'il
rencontrre la première c'est
l'insuffisance de la tarification qui
leur est accordée avec des couts de
reviens qui sont bien supérieurs à cette
tarification le coût de revient d'une
heure à domicile est par exemple de 32 €
et la Carsat ne prend en charge que 20
5,60 € je précise que la convention qui
lit cette association à la Carsat leur
interdit toute sa surfacturation d'un
reste à charge au bénéficiaire la mise
en place d'un reste à charge ne serait
par ailleurs pas forcément la meilleure
solution pour des bénéficiaires qui sont
parfois en situation de précarité et
qu'un reste à charge trop important
conduirait inévitablement à renoncer à
toute aide cette tarification
insuffisante mais gravement en péril la
survie financière de ces associations et
alors que la demande explose et on sait
que c'est une tendance qui va se
poursuivre nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
et plus que jamais de nos services
d'aide à domicile nombreux et de qualité
or beaucoup sont aujourd'hui en très
grande difficulté monsieur alors je vais
quand même vousoser la question mais
vous y avez déjà partiellement répondu
comment pensez-vous que on pourrait
faire évoluer la tarification au service
d'aide à domicile un nouveau mode de
financement qui prennent en compte le
temps de déplacement vous l'avez déjà un
peu expliqué par exemple est-il
envisageable ma deuxème question porte
sur les cisus c'est aujourd'hui un
dispositif qui permet d'employer une
personne à domicile y compris pour
l'accompagnement et l'aide à la personne
Les services à domicile sont à juste
titre soumis à des contrôles à une
réglementation ou encore à des
évaluations de la même manière que le
sont notamment les épades mais comment
sont exercés les contrôles des personnes
qui exercent via les césus ou le
contrôle de leur activité les plans d'
qui sont mis en place via les césus que
ce soit AC clapa ou la PCH le sont aussi
avec de l'argent public mais les
contrôles sement bien obscurs merci de
vos éclaircissements ah c'est une
question technique alors monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président il
y a pas mal de questions qui est touché
effectivement un problème qui me tient à
cœur comme l'a dit Jean-Marie vanon
derenberg c'est c'est effectivement ce
ce problème de de de l'uniformité ou de
l'universalité moi je préfère le terme
d'universalité au terme d'uniformité je
crois que il n'est pas sain exigit que
il se passe la même chose en lozer et à
la ville de Paris ou la même chose dans
le département du patcalé et dans le
département des pyinées orientales donc
ce que nous souhaitons c'est ce que nous
souhaitons ce que nous sommes devrions
exiger et plus que souhaiter c'est qu'il
y ait effectivement une comparabilité
des aides accordées aux personnes quel
que soit effectivement leur lieu de
domicile et et on touche là très vite à
un deuxième problème c'estàd j'ai j'ai
bien entendu le le le le le le
l'orientation vers la qualité est-ce que
euh avec des des des des mesures qui
seraient des mesures trop ambitieuses on
ne finirait pas par décourager les
innovations il y a actuellement un
travail qui est réalisé avec les
départements et où la la CNSA joue joue
un rôle un peu de de de maîre d'œuvre
c'est la réforme des dotations de la
CNSA au département cette réforme qui
est en cours c'est pas facile
croyez-moi cette réforme qui est en
cours elle doit elle doit aboutir à
plusieurs choses elle doit aboutir
notamment à ce
que les aides qui soient accordé soient
des aides qui soient proportionnelles
aux difficultés rencontré par les
différents départements euh l'égalité
complète est une rupture d'égalité
c'est-à-dire que jouer l'égalité c'est
traité différemment des départements qui
se trouvent dans des situations
différentes il faut effectivement que
certains départements soient davantage
aidés parce que leurs moyens sont des
moyens insuffisants quelquefois on a
fait le contraire c'est-à-dire on
parlait tout à l'heure de de de de des
tarifs planchés où vous avez
effectivement des départements riches
qui avaient des taux très très bas en
terme de tarif planchés euh qui sont
passés de 16 à 22 sans que ça leur coûte
quoi que ce soit alors que des
départements ruraux des départements
beaucoup moins favorisés avaient fait
l'effort parce que justement leur
population était une population en
difficulté d'avoir des tarifs planchés
plus importants euh ce qui fait que il y
a un effet d'obben qui s'est créé pour
un certain nombre de départements si on
réforme globalement les aides de la CNSA
au département on sera amené à revoir
également cet élément de même sur sur le
le problème de de de du forfait le
problème du forfait il il a la la la la
l'estime et la le soutien effectivement
du conseil de la CNSA une condition
c'est que la forfétisation n'entraîne
pas une diminution du temps passé au
chevet de la personne mais qu'elle
permett au contraire d'avoir une
beaucoup plus grande souplesse dans
l'organisation des services à domicile
que les les les les structures des
services à domicile que les les les les
les personnes qui pratiquent cette
fonction particulièrement noble soit
davantage mise à contribution pour
organiser leur emploi du temps je je me
suis un peu fâché à un conseil de de de
la CNSA où on on évoquait effectivement
les les heures qui sont les heures de de
de de de de lien social les 2 heures de
lien social les 9h par par mois qui sont
un élément extrêmement intéressant
intéressant pour la personne qui en
bénéficiera la personne âgée qui en
bénéficiera parce que encore une fois ce
ce ce n'est pas seulement lorsqu'il y a
des des gestes quasi médicaux ou
d'utilité absolue comme le fait de
préparer les repas et de donner à manger
qui seront réalisés mais lorsqu'il y
aura aussi le le le le le le
compagnonnage d'une personne vis-à-vis
de l'autre personne avec les
conversations avec le le le tour du
jardin avec les discussions qui pourront
se
faire j'ai entendu que certains
départements avait l'intention de
confier effectivement ces heures de lien
social à la poste j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie pour la Poste la question
n'est pas là elle a des facteurs dont
quelquefois elle sait plus trop bien
quoi faire mais que que la poste soit
chargée de faire un repérage par exemple
des personnes en difficulté soit mais
qu'elle soit chargée de réaliser ce
travail là je ne suis plus d'accord ce
travail doit être réalisé par les agents
qui sont aujourd'hui les agents qui
rendent ce service à la personne et que
cela permette passe d'un d'un d'un
emploi achuré en un emploi qui un peu à
la fois s'acheminera vers un emploi à
temps à temps complet encore une fois
quand on connaît le montant des salaires
qui sont perçus on ne peut que que que
rougir de
confusion Virginie complément c'est non
c'est bon si si vous m'y autorisez
peut-être beaucoup de choses ont été
abordé dans cette série de questions
revenir sur des points qui avaient moins
fait l'objet de euh d'information
d'abord en écho propos du du sénateur
mon sur le le tarif des épad et le
positionnement des épad privés
commerciaux sur l'accompagnement des des
publics les plus dépendants plusieurs
choses la CNSA est chargé depuis la loi
SV de de de rendre compte des des tarifs
de publier les tarifs hébergement des
des épad nous le faisons sur le site
pour les personnes âgées puis d'assurer
des synthèses régulières euh pour
l'information collective sur ces prix on
s'apprête à mettre la la main à la euh
publication des du prix des épates pour
l'année 23 qui nous permettra de euh de
rendre compte de de tarifs euh moyens
journaliers effectivement très
différents suivant que les épates sont
habilités ou non habilités à l'aide
sociale euh les écarts se situant pour
euh les prix hébergement des épas
d'habilité aux alentours de
63,50 € et pour ceux non habilités à
l'aide sociale en moyenne nationale euh
plus près de 97 € avec les prix qui
absolument sont surprise on le constate
chaque année depuis qu'on les publie euh
les plus les prix les plus élevés en
région parisienne 155 € en moyenne pour
Paris comme tarif journalier pour les
places d'abilité euh dans le les hautes
scènes 132 € dans les Yvelines 118 €
mais également en Haute Savoie 115 € euh
ces tarifs journaliers les plus élevés
pour les épades commerciaux coïncident
avec euh des départements euh dans
lesquels le prix du foncier est très
élevé c'est pour ça qu'on trouve
notamment la Haute Savoie et c'est
logique puisque le tarif éébergement il
rémunère en priorité euh le coût de
l'hébergement et donc il est très
déterminé comme on avait pu le mettre en
évidence dans des publications antérieur
par le prix du foncier
euh est-ce que ces prix euh qui sont
élevés sont que on a repéré des
disparités on n'a pas repéré les 1500 €
que vous évoquiez monsieur le sénateur
euh euh euh ces prix euh donc je le
redis ces prix hébergement ils sont
essentiellement déterminés par le coût
du foncier pour autant on voit que les
durées de séjour dans les établissements
sont différentes effectivement et plus
les épades sont coûteux plus la durée de
séjour est réduite c'est une forme de de
dernier recours
euh le pour autant enfin moi je
considère que ce n'est pas au seul épad
euh à ce moment-là de prendre en en
charge les publics très dépendants et et
multilypathologi qui peuvent alors être
être accueilli
onurant le mécanisme de financement du
soin apporté on n'est pas n'y suffirait
pas puisque ce qui est tarifé à travers
la le financement
Patos n'inclut ne va pas jusqu'au soins
palliatifs mais je veux signaler
notamment à la faveur de la crise covid
que les lien entre les épades et les
filières gériatriques ou gérontologiques
et les structures d'hospitalisation à
domicile se sont renforcé et que à ce
moment-là j'allais dire le juste soin ou
le juste accompagnement il résulte pas
seulement de la mobilisation des
ressources propres de l'épad mais des
conventionnements entre l'Pad et ses
filières ou cette
had le bilan d'ailleurs de
l'intervention des des des des
structures had sur l'année 23 on un
teste il y a un renforcement des liens
et des partenariats et c'est absolument
indispensable pour garantir le bon
accompagnement de public qui peuvent
être effectivement en fin de vie euh
dans dans les EPAD je veux
aussi réagir ou apporter des des des
informations sur
euh le soutien euh
à que la la caisse est susceptible
d'apporter au département qui promuve
l'accueil familial pour les personnes
âgées pour signaler que dans le cadre
des euh rencontre autonomie
interdépartementale que la CNSA a
installé cette année dans le cadre de la
création de la branche je me
rendaz au tout début du mois de novembre
à la Réunion qui fait partie des
territoires dans
lequel et pratiqué et promu l'accueil
familial j'ai pu notamment visiter des
maisons d'accueillants familiaux un peu
sur le modèle des maisons d'assistants
maternels qui peuvent exister sur le
champ de l'enfance et euh enfin avec
l'équipe qui m'accompagna on a été très
intéressé euh par ce modèle qui euh voit
euh euh des maisons euh donc tout à fait
comparable à un habitat
euh autonome à une maison avec trois
effectivement trois maximum quatre
résidents un autre qui est là en
permanence euh le modèle que nous avons
vu en fait était assez original puisque
sur le modèle de de maison d'agant
familiale la maison était gérée par une
asso assciation qui salarié
l'accueillant familial étant lui-même
agréé et ce modèle permettait d'avoir
deux accueillants familiaux enfin qui se
succèd au sein d'une maison qui était un
vrai chez soi pour les personnes
mobilisant par ailleurs puisqu'il y
avait plusieurs petites maisons dans un
même quartier et donc une capacité à
pouvoir disposer aussi mobiliser des
services civique disposer d'espace pour
des regroupements et des activités donc
c'est vrai que c'était un un modèle qui
nous apparu très séduisant et sur lequel
il faut qu'on continue de travailler
puisque garantissant un petit chez soi
et en même temps en capacité de voilà de
d'offrir des activités très
intéressantes pour pour les
pensionnaires on continue peut-êre
encore il reste trois dernières
questions donc avant que avant avant la
coupure et et voilà la suspension
euh Brigitte de vessard oui merci
Président je tenais à remercier monsieur
le Président et Madame la Directrice
pour leurs propos évidemment plein de
choses ont été dites et je vais pas être
redondante je voudrais juste faire un
focus sur euh sur euh la question que je
vais vous poser en tous les cas le alors
euh sur le titre 2 vous parlez de enfin
il est dit promouvoir euh la
bientraitance euh pour lutter contre la
maltraitance des personnes en situation
vulnérabl alors on sait que la
maltraitance prend plusieurs formes moi
je voudrais faire un focus sur le
service d'aide à domicile euh moi je
suis évidemment une élue qui va beaucoup
sur le terrain et qui R rcontre
énormément de familles qui se plaignent
qui se plaignent parce que dans ces
services malheureusement d'aide à
domicile on a parlé mes collègues l'ont
parlé du recrutement qui est difficile à
faire de la formation qui est pas
toujours opérationnelle mais qu'en
est-il parce que nous sommes quand même
des familles sont complètement
désœuvrées quand vous avez des familles
qui prennent en compte la situation de
leurs parents vieillissants et qui sont
présentes elles peuvent Pier à toutes
ces incohérence à ces maltraitances qu'
sont qui sont pas forcément parfois
volontaires mais qui existe qui existe
alors moi je peux en parler puisque j'ai
vécu cette situation mais je ne suis pas
la seule beaucoup beaucoup la vivent et
on n' pas le sentiment d'avoir des
contrôles qui sont renforcés des moyens
qui sont alloués pour vérifier vous avez
par exemple sur des services d'aide à
domicile dans une semaine qui est qui
est programmée vous avez des absences
les personnes sont pas remplacées
elles sont étrangère aussi elles
arrivent pour la première fois dans une
famille la personne ne connaît pas cette
cette aide à domicile donc il faut un
peu réexpliquer personne n' le temps de
rien du tout et quand il y a vraiment de
la maltraitance sur lesquelles les
famillees sont informé et quand je parle
de maltraitance et parfois ça va plus
loin quand vous déposez plainte il y a
pas de suivi c'est pas pris en compte au
regard finalement on met en balance le
le témoignage des des comment dirais-je
des personnes qui viennent travailler à
domicile contre une personne qui est
âgée en considérant qu'elle peut être
sénile et qu'elle raconte n'importe quoi
donc moi je suis je suis très inquiète
quand même sur les moyens que vous
mettez à disposition pour renforcer ces
contrôles qui sont indispensabl parce
que aujourd'hui il existe de la
maltraitance effectivement dans certains
éepad mais à domicile également comment
faire pour améliorer je dirais le
quotidien de toutes ces personnes qui
souhaitent encore rester à domicile dont
les familles sont là mais elles ne
peuvent pas parce qu'elles travaillent
donc je trouve que là il y a de la
gravité ça n'est pas ça n'est pas suivi
des faits et je le répète les familles
sont désœuvrés face à ça voilà je vous
remercie merci qualifé qualifé merci
monsieur le Président je vais être aussi
rapide merci Madame merci monsieur le
Président moi je voulais rejoindre les
on sera deux chers collègues vos
inquiétudes concernant ces couches
multiples qu'on rajoute qu'on rajoute
j'ai l'impression qu'on fait du
palliatif avec avec les dispositifs et
je voulais être le porte-parole des
départements qui sont entre Guill les
bons élèves qui ont essayé pour des
sujets qu'on évoque aujourd'hui à
trouver des solutions sans que cette
solution soit on est un peu dans le
système D mais qui a prouvé ses preuves
puis maintenant on arrive avec une
nouvelle couche supplémentaire qui qui
risque de déstabiliser les départements
qui sont déjà et vous le savez très bien
vous étiez président de département qui
sont en difficulté aujourd'hui ça c'est
juste une une remarque la deuxième vous
aviez parlé des PPL c'est vrai que ça
reste des vœux des vœux de pour ce qui
nous concerne nous avons adopté à
l'unanimité au Sénat mais je dis bien à
l'unanimité un amendement concernant le
dispositif Creton hein 10000 personnes
qui sont en attente 10000 personnes qui
embolis des structures d'me ça a été
voté à l'unanimité on aimerait bien que
le gouvernement sen en part et qu'on
voit qu'on voit la réalisation de ce
projet euh à titre expérimental en tout
cas pour commencer parce que l'article
40 nous interdit beaucoup de choses
quelle est votre position sur ce point
particulier merci merci pour terminer
Frédéric puissa merci monsieur le
Président très très rapidement merci
monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice c'est vrai que dans ce texte
de loi il y a des choses et il y en a
qui me semble n'y sont pas et puis à ce
qui est du domaine du réglementaire et
du législatif il me semble qu'il n'y a
rien dans ce texte de loi sur l'accueil
de jour et notamment pour les personnes
atteintes de de maladies d'Alzheimer et
et d'autres du du trouble du
comportement or on sait effectivement
que ces dispositifs d'accueil relèvent
plutôt du réglementaire he parce que
c'est une circulaire he qui qui organise
notamment les les places d'accueil de
jour et et les seuils minimals d'accueil
de jour de 6 et 10 pour pour pour pour
qu'on puisse effectivement ouvrir des
places que cette circulaire date de 2011
et on sait aussi qu'il y a eu des des
adaptations de cette circulaire
notamment sur le terrain on s'est rendu
compte qu'effectivement on pouvait
déroger à cette circulaireve avec des
places qui parfois parfois pouvaient
être de deux ou de trois euh moi
j'aurais souhaité avoir votre avis sur
le sujet pourquoi est-ce que je vous
pose cette question parce que on
s'aperçoit que l'ARS fait le tour
actuellement d'un certain nombre
d'établissements et considère que deux
places trois places ce n'est pas
suffisant se référent du reste à la
circulaire et ferme ses places d'accueil
de jour or on sait que la notion de
distance pour les places d'accueil de
jour est quand même quelque chose qui
est très important les gens onont pas
faire des kilomè pour effectivement
pouvoir avoir de l'aide notamment dans
dans dans un cadre familial est-ce que
un vous avez entendu parler de de de
cette de ce type d'attitude des des ARS
de que pensez-vous de ce seuil de 6 et
de 10 et tr est-ce qu'on peut pas mettre
au niveau législatif ce qui est
aujourd'hui du domaine du réglementaire
pour essayer de ne pas le régidifier
mais plutôt de l'adapter au terrain
merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président bien sur le le
le les amendements que
Creton
il y a des choses qui ont été faites
notamment au niveau PLFSS il y a les
30000 dans les 30000 solutions il y a
aussi la volonté effectivement de faire
en sorte de créer des places de façon à
pouvoir un peu à la fois faire en sorte
que cette solution pe une une solution
mauvaise mais indispensable des
amendements cotau
puissent appartenir bientôt au passé
donc sur ce point-là il y a des des des
des des des progrès et notamment le le
dernier le dernier PLFSS marque
effectivement un prrs sur les les les
dérives qui peuvent exister au niveau
des Sades je pense que la la seule
solution elle est globale c'est-à-dire
que la globalité c'est faire en sorte
que les les personnels soient mieux
formés que les personnels soient plus
nombreux que le sens donner
effectivement à à ce métier soit plus
plus plus plus perceptible demain qu'il
ne l'est aujourd'hui il y a aussi des
exemples extrêmement nombreux de
personne qui a se dévoue sans compter
pour des salaires de misère
effectivement assez responsabilité et
qui assume en dehors de toute
rémunération ce ce qu'on naccepte pas de
le rémunérer aujourd'hui parce que ces
personnes estiment que c'est
indispensable pour la personne qu'elles
aideent je regrette aussi la la la
féminisation outrancière si vous voulez
de cette fonction 97 % dit-on des des
personnes on a bien au niveau des
départements on est bien arriver à à à
faire en sorte que pour les assistants
familiaux par exemple il y ait davantage
d'hommes qui soi recrutés on arrive
aujourd'hui certainement à une
proportion de 70 30 il faut qu'on y
parvienne de la même manière et toutes
les exemples que j'ai eu effectivement
de personnes aide à domicile du sexe
masculin euh ont bien marché et et ont
été effectivement des des des des
exemples qui pour moi sont sont des
exemples à développer sur la crainte que
vous avez je peux la comprendre que les
les départements les meilleurs sont en
quelque sorte pénalisés euh c'est c'est
ce qui arrive relativement fréquemment
c'est encore une fois le tarif plancher
c'est ça c'est à euh plus vous étiez
mauvais et plus vous avez été compensé
intégralement de ce que vous n'avez pas
fait jusqu'àors bon même si le tarif
planché dans dans son idée même était
une idée satisfaisante alors je suis un
peu moins moins pessimiste que vous sur
l'évolution et des tarifs quand vous
dites 32 € effectivement pour le le le
le prix euh on est maintenant euh à
vraissemblablement entre 24 et 25 he
pour l'année 2024 on ne sait pas encore
exactement ce que ce sera à cela vous
pouvez ajouter dans certains cas de F
mais qui sont quand même de plus de plus
en plus nombreux les 3 € effectivement
de qualité on arrive à 27 on était il y
a pas si longtemps on était à 16 donc il
y a déjà effectivement des progrès
importants qui ont été réalisés je crois
que les progrès qui restent à faire
c'est des progrès dans la qualité du
recrutement et dans le le le le le la
limitation également des des des des des
vacances de poste des des des des congés
maladie pourquoi il y a-t-il autant de
congés maladies parce que aujourd'hui
cette profession est la profession qui
est considérée comme étant la plus
dangereuse
plus que les fonctions effectivement de
de de des travaux publics qui a ont
longtemps occupé la la médaille d'or sur
la dangerosité du métier pourquoi
sont-elles aussi dangereuses parce que
les aides techniques vis-à-vis des
personnes ne sont pas suffisamment
utilisées et parce que la formation
n'est pas suffisante et parce que
peut-être quand on arrive à un certain
âge il faudrait effectivement qu'il y
ait de manière systématique des
décisions qui soient prises consistant
par exemple à ce que la personne qui n'a
plus la force physique pour exercer ce
métier devienne une personne de
ressources pour ses jeunes collègues
comme ça se fait là aussi pour pour les
assistants familiaux euh voilà quelques
remarque que je souhaitais
faire allez je vous donne Madame la
Directrice le dernier mot voilà chouette
euh alors en réaction ou en réponse ou
en complément aux interrogations sur la
qualité des accompagnements et les
risque de de de de maltraitance euh vous
vous
soullignez euh les difficultés qui sont
posées pour les personnes elles-mêmes
pour les familles
par des interventions trop fractionné
des absences non remplacées ou ou ou un
turnover des
intervenantes qui sont tous tous des
symptômes des difficultés ou des
tensions he qui existent
sur le le recrutement et la fidélisation
des professionnels de
l'autonomie c'est
c'est un sujet effectivement central
auquel d'ailleurs la CNSA a consacré ses
dernières rencontrre innovation
recherche qui sont tenu en novembre sur
la question justement des métiers de
l'autonomie euh
qui métiers qui comme ceux d'une manière
globale métiers sociaux sont en tension
vous savez qu'un livre blanc a été remis
au gouvernement et et et vraiment le
soutien l'attractivité de ces métiers
qui appelle une mobilisation collective
et la mobilisation de très nombreux
lebiers qui tiennent à la rémunération
des professionnels aux conditions
effectivement de de de leur recrutement
du fonctionnement des services de
promouvoir des organisations qui soient
bien traitantes moi je veux souligner
que si la CNSA elle n'intervient pas
dans le contrôle des des structures qui
incombe aux autorités de tarification et
de contrôle donc au premier chef les
départements et les ARS c'est les RS
intervenants sous l'égide du du
ministère et d'une coordination des
contrôles qui mobilise notamment l'IGAS
nous sommes nous nous faisons partie des
acteurs mobilisés donc pour promouvoir à
la fois des des organisations bien
trraitantes sur le champ de l'aide
àomicile nous avons initié à cette fin
une étude d'évaluation très importante
du fonctionnement des services en équipe
autonome qui doit aboutir l'année
prochaine et qui doit nous permettre de
voilà de de de promouvoir de manière
étayée ce fonctionnement possible comme
une manière de
de de rompre avec des interventions trop
minuté et de de donner plus d'autonomie
aux professionnels qui interviennent en
accompagnement bah précisément hein pour
euh euh comment dire conforter des
interventions au plus près en proximité
donc éviter les interventions fractionné
les temps de de de
déplacement favoris l'autonomie des des
professionnels qui est précisément ce
qui les conduit à choisir ses métiers
euh donc on doit pouvoir partager avec
les structures ces modes d'organisation
et nous soutenons aussi par des
conventionnements que nous que nous
passons avec les grandes fédérations
d'aide à domicile dans le cadre de la
qualité de service où nous mobilisons
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
hein dans ces conventions qui
soutiennent la formation des
professionnels euh le la formation des
managers de ces équipes euh en sorte
qu'ils puissent être sensibilisé
justement à euh des euh mode
d'organisation biraitant et euh à au
développement de formation à la
bientraitance à la lutte contre la
maltraitance pour leurs professionnels
on a des programmes qui ont quelques
années déjà euh et qui euh et qui
donnent des résultats probants c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faut revenir
constamment que le travail sur cette
culture de promotion de la bienenttraite
qui vise aussi à installer et ça ça fait
tout à fait éch aux préoccupations du
conseil à à à à redire que les personnes
sont des sujets de droit jusqu'au bout
ell sont pas des objets de soins et la
première bientraitance consiste à
s'assurer du plein consentement de la
personne au soins l'accompagnement qui
lui est prodigué euh donc on a vraiment
un effort collectif à faire et la CNSA
de mobiliser plusieurs levier de la
formation de l'accompagnement des
fédérations euh de la promotion
d'organisation bientraitante pour faire
progresser cette qualité de service euh
et puis sur la question de l'accueil et
du développement des places de de RPI
souligner qu'un un l'IGAS avait été
missionné euh l'an dernier a pu rendre
un un rapport important sur le soutien
aux aidants en lesevant les freins au
développement justement des euh euh des
solutions de RP euh donc oui nous savons
que euh euh le fait de euh de
conditionner euh la capacité des
structures à à organiser des des des
séjours de répi un certain nombre de
places minimum peut être un Flin à leur
développement en même temps et le
rapport il Gasse le souligner euh nous
constatons et les ARS avec nous euh avec
dépis que les structures de ri
lorsqu'elles existent ne sont les places
ne sont pas peuvent être très
sous-occupées donc il y a il y
a ou
ou et donc en tout cas je je je pense
qu'il y a une vraie réflexion et dans le
cadre de la nouvelle stratégie aans pour
pouvoir développer plusieurs types de
répis y compris à
domicile qui pour le coup répond
parfaitement au besoins des des aidants
de pouvoir être soutenu avec des
intervenants qui viennent à domicile et
qui du coup ne perdurb pas j'allais dire
le euh le le mode de vie de la de la
personne aidée qui conserve ses
habitudes donc c'est une combinaison de
type
oui ouais merci beaucoup euh je
vais mêre un terme à notre audition une
longue audition hein merci beaucoup
monsie président madamerice il y avait
beaucoup de questions merci à nos
rapporteurs je sais que la fin de
l'année est un peu chargée pour eux
parce que on va reprendre nos travaux
directement avec le texte et donc il y a
beaucoup d'auditions notamment tout
début tout début janvier un grand merci
à vous voilà il me reste maintenant à
vous souhaiter tout simplement de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année prenez du temps
l'année 2023 a été chargé donc prenez le
temps de vous reposer pour revenir en
force en 2024 je vous invite pour un
moment de convivialité dans mon bureau
qui est juste à côté voilà qui est le
bureau de la commission et en tous les
cas un grand merci pour votre
assiduité à tout de
suite